egal ob es da oder normalo restaurant
und kneipenbesuche sie sind für uns alle
immer noch ein riesiger bürokratischer
aufwand sind nachweise zeigen womöglich
auch noch einen aktuellen test
personalausweis nervt natürlich und da
gibt es vielerorts noch die verhasste
sperrstunde die es den gastronomen
extrem schwer macht endlich wieder
umsatz zu verzeichnen in hamburg da geht
diese sperrstunde von 23 bis 5 uhr und
wir waren gestern abend mal auf der
reeperbahn dem legendären herzstück des
hamburger party lebens beim zu schließen
dabei
normalerweise trocken hier die letzten
gäste in den frühen morgenstunden nach
hause aber im moment ist der frust groß
seit dezember gilt zusätzlich zum
tanzverbot eine sperrstunde ab 23 uhr
die hamburger sind sauer denn in
dänemark nicht weit weg gab es bereits
den freedom day nur in der hansestadt
wird nicht gelockert stadt tech noten
ist hier tote hose die gäste die
überhaupt noch kommen sind genervt ist
natürlich kein vergleich zu vor corinna
damit manfred vormachen das virus wird
sich um die uhr nicht auf einmal
überlegungen dass es sich jetzt immer
mehr ausbreitet deswegen ich glaube das
thema im sinnhaftigkeit von corona
regeln das hat er jetzt die letzten zwei
jahre schon seit zwei jahren nicht mehr
hier und es ist also die ganze stimmung
ist halt nicht so hier und ja man etwas
anderes wenn man hierher kommt und wer
sein geld auf der reeperbahn verdient
hat jetzt natürlich ein problem gerade
wie jetzt globales nach club um 23 uhr
kommen da waren alle gäste und jetzt
müssen wir schließen ist natürlich
fürchterlich ich lebe hier auf dem kiez
ich fahre hier taxi seit sieben jahren
viel für gastronomen auch fürs rotlicht
und für künstler und ja die
sperrschilder und jetzt gerade aber das
ist nicht tragbar es ist einfach sinnlos
tja endlich wieder ein normales leben
das fordern immer mehr menschen seit
bild ja diese woche den countdown zur
freedom week eingeleitet hat die fotos
auf der videowand hier die sind immer
mehr geworden im laufe der woche und
jetzt kommen weitere stimmen dazu ist
der koch und gastronom ralf zacherl ist
uns zugeschaltet und der hygiene arzt
professor klaus die zastrow schönen
guten morgen
wunderschön und mortara in schweden in
dänemark in england überall wurde der
freedom day schon gefeiert wir fordern
hier die freedom weg würden sie sich
dieser forderungen anschließen
ja auf der einen seite also ja ich hab
da ja da schlagen zwei herzen in meiner
brust auf der einen seite als gastronom
wird sich natürlich so schnell wie
möglich wieder keine einschränkungen auf
der anderen seite möchte ich natürlich
dass meine gäste und das personal
natürlich auch geschützt sind also ich
hoffe aber das wird demnächst bald
wieder normal arbeiten dürfen herr
zastrow aus medizinischer sicht wäre
denn ein ende der maßnahmen tatsächlich
jetzt auch schon vertretbar
ja auf jeden fall wir müssen uns ja mal
anschauen was ist den letzten zwei drei
monaten passiert
alle möglichen maßnahmen sind eingesetzt
wurden und trotzdem sind die zahlen nach
oben gegangen das heißt also die
maßnahmen haben überhaupt nicht gewirkt
denn sonst hätten marcel die zahlen
runter gehen müssen also das hat
natürlich auch was damit zu wählen wir
sagen wir immer fehleranalyse ursache
korrektur aber
fehleranalyse und ursache macht hier
kein mensch die es werden
schreckensnachrichten verbreitet und
nicht so werden wir vielleicht 500 1000
fälle haben und das stimmt aber ich
dafür gibt es keine evidenz dafür gibt
es gar nichts es gibt keinerlei hinweise
wir müssen doch immer wieder einmal
fragen wo kommt das virus her aus dem
mund oder beziehungsweise ist wird in
den mund übertragen weshalb das einzige
was wir wirklich haben und da plädiere
ich dann trotzdem dafür ist dass man den
mund nasen schutz tragen sollte aber
auch da sage ich mal wir keine echte
pflicht inzwischen sind nach zwei jahren
die leute so weit doch geschult und
wissen bescheid und auch zum eigenschutz
habe mit vielen leuten gesprochen haben
in kona vorbei ist trage ich trotzdem
bin der grippewelle ist usw die maske
die japaner machen da sowieso die
angesagt für die maske brauchten die
kinder haben wir vorher schon gemacht
herr zastrow ich würde herrn zeit zwei
zeit hier würde gern auch wieder in die
runde holen hat wie wie hoch sind die
ausfälle die einnahme außerhalb die
finanziellen einbußen die sie schon
erleiden mussten
also sagen wir so ich meinen die letzten
zwei jahre waren einfach eine
vollkatastrophe waren im schnitt
eigentlich fast 40 prozent weniger
umsatz
nein durch die 2g plus nie gelungen ist
uns das gesamte weihnachtsgeschäft
zerbombt worden dazu wir hatten keine
einzige große weihnachtsfeier und von
der kleineren weihnachtsfeiern hatten
wir vielleicht die hälfte von denen wir
normalerweise brüten führt hätten und
das problem ist natürlich eine ganze
kolonie man kann man keinen restaurant
nicht irgendwie halb auf machen also
entweder man macht das ganz auf das
heißt ich habe halt dann die die volle
last der kosten und das personal und
fixkosten angeht aber ich mache ein
gemälde im im schnitt nur 60 bis 80
prozent vom umsatz und das reichen um
die gastronomie halt nicht zu überleben
muss ich hoffe auch wirklich dass die
politik dann noch mal ein bisschen nach
steuert weil der dezember umsatz und der
umsatz war halt kein vergleich zu
2009/10 und das sind jetzt also gerade
bei uns im spitzen cohen berlin
eigentlich die umsatzstärksten monate
und wir konnten uns einfach mit dem
ganze regelung die ganzen chefs der
firmen mehrmals gesagt wenn ich nicht
mit 100 leuten feiern möchte aber ich
hab halt zwölf leute die nicht geimpft
sind ein personal feier ist ja auch
einer teambuilding veranstaltung und
wenn ich dann irgendwie einen teil der
angestellten nicht dabei habe sage ich
einfach die ganze weihnachtsfeier ab und
zu was halten großes problem ist
natürlich auch dass wir wieder mal
diesen berüchtigten flickenteppiche in
deutschland haben in einigen ländern
gilt zweig plus in anderen nur zwei
gehen einen zweig plus drin und nur
zweig außen die eine mit maske die
anderen ohne die anderen haben wieder 3g
also dieses wirrwarr ist natürlich auch
ein großes problem und schluss mit dem
wirrwarr soll man mal kurz eine stimme
dazu holen das fordert auch alec völkel
der boss hoss sänger und zwar für den
kulturbereich wir haben mal was er uns
gesagt hat
heute jeder weiß die kulturen
musikbranche war besonders hart
betroffen die letzten zwei jahre
wirtschaftlich sinnvolle konzert und zu
nehmen wann nicht möglich wir fordern
von der politik eine eröffnungs
strategie eine klare zusage eigentlich
das im sommer alles wieder offen ist wir
wieder auf die bühne kommen wir als
poster zu versuchen das dritte jahr in
folge jetzt eine sommertournee zu
organisieren wir brauchen einheitliche
maßnahmen wir brauchen das bundesweite
wir brauchen das verlässlich die fans
warten wir warten wir wollen wieder auf
die bühne
hast du also bundesweit sollen die
maßnahmen fallen aber wir wissen ja nun
die länder entscheiden tatsächlich was
wäre für sie aus ihrer sicht aus
medizinischer sicht ein sinnvolles
öffnungs konzept
das ist kein großes konzept wir können
also sagen die maßnahmen die bisher
durchgeführt sollen das ist ja im
wesentlichen alles absonderung maßnahmen
also restaurants schließen und
sperrstunde machen usw das zielt ja
alles überhaupt nicht auch das virus
werden maßnahmen getroffen die
letztendlich wie auch schon ein paar der
zuschauer folgen wirklich sinnlos sind
und dass sie eben wissenschaftlich
überhaupt nicht begründet sind erkennt
man ja daran dass in jedem bundesland
was anderes gemacht und wieder sagt ja
es ist wissenschaftlich begründet nein
es ist überhaupt hält ist lang unser
denn durch die isolierung und
absonderung kriegen das nicht hin also
alle maßnahmen weg außer maske den
leuten dringend empfehlen die maske zu
tragen natürlich auch die impfung ist er
braucht einfach hilft gewusst natürlich
wird ist ganz schön schwierig wenn man
auf der einen seite nach einer
impfpflicht schreibt ja und dann aber
sah aber dann bist du trotzdem noch lang
und nicht geschützt und du kannst auch
weiterhin andere anstecken da sagt auch
jeder impfgegner wozu soll ich mich denn
impfen lassen hinter der gleiche ist wie
vorher also
was da so kommuniziert wird ist auch ein
humbug also alles diese isolierung und
rettungsmaßnahmen weg und mund
nasenschutz fragen denn das ist das
einzige loch aus dem das virus kommt und
wenn wir das richtig einheiten wir
hatten ja damals schon schwierigkeiten
am anfang die ersten vier monate haben
die wissenschaftler die die sogenannten
wissenschaftler
und politiker gesagt der mund
nasenschutz hat überhaupt gar keine
wirkung das ist blödsinn ist eine
virenschleuder hat die kanzlerin müsse
also
das bleibt bei den leuten natürlich auch
haften ja
und aber trotzdem ist der montage schuss
das einzige was für im momentan und und
alles andere kann man sich schenken
alles klar herr zastrow hat halt ganz
herzlichen dank dass sie hier heute bei
uns dabei waren und das trotz
angesprochen impfpflicht dazu ist heute
auch eine wichtige entscheidung am
heutigen tag in karlsruhe gefallen freie
fahrt für die einrichtungs bezogenen
pflicht heißt es da aus karlsruhe die
richter am bundesverfassungsgericht habe
neben den eilantrag zur aussetzung der
impfpflicht für das pflegepersonal
abgelegt die begründung der sehr
geringen wahrscheinlichkeit von
gravierenden folgen einer impfung steht
die deutlich höhere wahrscheinlichkeit
einer beschädigung von leib und leben
wohl habe also besonders verletzlicher
menschen gegenüber das ist ja eine eil
entscheidung jetzt gewesen ein
hauptverfahren kommt dann noch und dann
wird der antrag noch mal ganz genau
verhandelt